IN FIELD HOSPITALS.
>> Sandra: MIKE TOBIN
REPORTING ON DETROIT FOR US.
>> Ed: FOX NEWS ALERT,
MARYLAND SAYS MARYLAND CURRENTLY
HAS MORE THAN 5500 CASES AND
MORE THAN 120 DEATHS.
JOINING ME NOW, THE GOVERNOR OF
MARYLAND, LARRY HOGAN.
GOVERNOR, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, EDDIE.
>> Ed: YOU WILL HAVE TO
FORGIVE ME, GOVERNOR CUOMO MAY
BE HAVING A PRESS CONFERENCE IN
A FEW MOMENTS.
YOU’VE GOTTEN HIGH MARKS FOR
WHAT YOU’VE DONE ON THE GROUND
AND YOU ACTED EARLY AND TRIED TO
DEAL WITH THIS.
TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED AT THIS
HOUR IN YOUR STATE.
>> ARE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO CLIMB
CLIMB, WE TOOK AGGRESSIVE AND
EARLY ACTION IN OUR STATE AND WE
ARE HOPING TO LESSEN THE
PROBLEMS HERE.
BUT IN THE BALTIMORE AND
WASHINGTON COURT OR WE ARE NOW
AT ABOUT 12,000 AND PROBABLY
ABOUT FIFTH OR SIXTH IN THE
NATION.
WE HAVE ABOUT 5 MILLION PEOPLE
IN BETWEEN THOSE TWO CITIES AND
OUR NUMBERS CONTINUE TO RISE
FAIRLY RAPIDLY, NOT THE KIND OF
SITUATION YOU HAVE A NEW YORK.
IT’S AN AREA THAT NOW YOU HAVE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOCUS ON
AS THE WASHINGTON AND
METROPOLITAN AREA ALL THE WAY
THROUGH BALTIMORE.
OUR STATE HAS A PRETTY GOOD
POPULATION CENTER THERE
SURROUNDING THOSE TWO CITIES
WHERE WE GOT ISSUES AND IT’S
GROWING RAPIDLY.
>> Ed: WHAT ARE YOU SEEING IN
TERMS OF HOSPITALIZATIONS?
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH WHAT YOU
ARE GOING THROUGH NOW A FEW DAYS
AGO OR A WEEK AGO AND THEY ARE
NOW SEEING HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
NEW PATIENTS GOING INTO THE
HOSPITAL AND COMING DOWN.
ARE YOU LAGGING BEHIND THEM
WHERE HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE STILL
GOING UP?
>> SO WE ARE MAYBE TEN DAYS-2
WEEKS BEHIND NEW YORK AND
LOUISIANA BUT WE ARE HOPING TO
NOT NEARLY BE AS BAD BECAUSE WE
TOOK ACTIONS SEVERAL WEEKS
EARLIER THAN THEY DID.
I WAS THE FIRST GOVERNOR IN
AMERICA TO DECLARE THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND ONE OF THE FIRST
OR SECOND TO CLOSE ALL OF THE
SCHOOLS STATEWIDE.
WE’VE BEEN REALLY AGGRESSIVE FOR
THE PAST 35 DAYS AND WE ARE
HOPING THAT THAT WILL DAMPEN
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS BUT WE ARE
DEFINITELY AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE CLIMB AS OPPOSED TO SORT OF
AT THE APEX WHERE WE BELIEVE
THEY ARE AND THEY ARE HOPEFULLY
STARTING TO FLATTEN OUT.
WE ARE HOPING OUR CLIMB ISN’T AS
STEEP BUT WE ARE STILL A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AWAY, TEN OR 14 DAYS
FROM REACHING THE TOP.
>> Ed: GOT IT.
WHAT ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES?
THEY’VE BEEN DOING HEROIC DEEDS
COME AFTER THEY HAVE THE GEAR
THEY NEED IN THEIR STATE?
>> THEY ARE JUST INCREDIBLE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
FOR THE REST OF US AND MY HEART
AND MY APPRECIATION GOES OUT TO
THEM.
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO GET THEM THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
NEED TO COME UP THE MASK, THE
SHIELDS AND THE GOWNS.
BUT IT’S A DIFFICULT SITUATION
WE ARE ALL DEALING WITH AND
EVERY ONE OF OUR STATES AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND EACH OF THE STATES
AS BEING AS AGGRESSIVE AS WE CAN
TO HELP OUR HOSPITALS AND
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS GET THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO THOSE HOT
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ON THE FRONT
LINES.
>> Ed: LAST QUESTION IN TERMS
OF FIGURING OUT THE SCHOOLS
MOVING FORWARD, SOME GOVERNORS
HAVE SAID THEY ARE PROBABLY DONE
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR AND OTHERS
SAYING THEY ARE HOPING TO GET
SOME SCHOOL TIME BACK.
I HAVE TO ADMIT I HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST HERE
BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER WANTS TO
KNOW IF YOU CAN HELP WITH HER
HOMEWORK.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, WHAT’S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND?
>> I’D BE HAPPY TO HELP HER WITH
HER HOMEWORK A LITTLE BIT.
[LAUGHS]
SCHOOLS USUALLY ARE ENDING HERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF JUNE AND WE
WILL WAIT AND SEE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS EXACTLY WHERE WE
ARE AND HOW MUCH WE ARE ABLE TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE AND WHAT
HAPPENS.
THE SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT IS
WORKING WITH ALL OF OUR 24 LOCAL
SUPERINTENDENTS TO TRY TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AND IN THE
MEANTIME THEY ARE TRYING TO DO
DISTANCE LEARNING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE ONLINE AND SENDING
HOMESCHOOL PLANS.
WE WOULD LOVE TO GET THEM BACK
OPEN BUT WE DON’T WANT TO DO
THAT IF IT’S NOT SAFE.
>> Ed: I’VE BEEN GETTING THE
EMAILS AND YOU’VE BEEN GETTING
LAPTOPS TO THOSE WHO NEED THEM.